I've been at Google nearly 10 years on,
literally for every one of those 10 years,
Andrew has been banging on about the shortcomings of the Internet,
um,
on just know that everybody else is,
has joined the game.
He's moving on ever the contrarian to,
to something else.
So the,
the,
the new book,
it's certainly not without its criticisms,
trenching criticisms of,
uh,
of silicon valley,
but also there's,
there's suggestions on how to,
uh,
to fix the future and resolve some of the issues that he has banged on a boat
for so long.
So,
um,
welcome Andrew.
Thank you peta.
And it's nice to be a wonderful,
uh,
audience,
spend a turnout.
So I suspect you are going to tell us.
Um,
you told us.
So.
Yeah,
I,
I firstly I made a lot of mistakes as well and one of my books,
I predicted that Facebook wouldn't survive,
so I am not as precious as I'd like to think I am.
I think I was a little lucky and I think I took a gamble on cal to the amateur
in 2007.
I mean,
it seemed obvious to me,
but it could have easily ended in a different way.
I mean,
I don't mean anything inevitable about it.
So,
uh,
I think I was a little lucky and,
um,
and I've made many errors along the way,
so I don't want to sound too cocky here.
And you talk early on in the book about do you think I was right?
Uh,
we'll,
we'll talk about that in due course.
Interesting to talk the normally some important points.
You definitely made some important points and I think that's a diplomatic way of
saying I was right on some of the points that I would disagree with.
But,
uh,
I always joke about my book,
my book's come out,
people always come up to me sort of half apologetically and they say,
we,
we kind of agree with 60% of what you write.
And I always joke and it's not really a joke,
we'll it away.
So
will you talk early on about you?
You said there's,
there,
there's people who are,
yes,
there's prepared no one,
the people who are maybe,
and you say you're a maybe.
So what does that mean?
Well,
maybe means that the revolution,
the digital revolution,
that you guys are engineering more than anyone else,
it has a huge potential.
It's the great event of the early part of the 21st century.
In many ways,
it's the equivalent of the mid 19th century,
early 20th century industrial revolution.
The next chapter,
or you know,
some people call it the second machine age,
the fourth industrial revolution.
Um,
it hasn't,
I think in overall terms,
it hasn't lived up to its billing.
We were promised democracy,
more equality,
more jobs,
a renascence of culture.
I don't think we've got the,
I think we might get it maybe,
but at the moment it's not there
terms that you use right the way through the book.
Maybe you should explain what you described as Moore's law,
which is not Myrryrs law,
but as Moore's law.
Uh,
but you,
you talked a lot about that and you also talk about team human and what it to be
human
or Mozilla was.
My phrase team human actually is Douglas Rushkoff's.
I stole that one from him.
But,
um,
uh,
you all know of course.
Um,
Gordon Moore's law,
uh,
the law,
I think he,
he came up with it originally.
It was just a throwaway remark in 1965 the computer chips with double in power
every 18 months or two years as the engine of the digital revolution.
And usually when you read these books about,
you know,
industry 3.0 and the second industrial revolution and the second machine age,
there's always an opening chapter on Moore's law as the engine,
as the driver of the change.
It's clearly a,
a law or a scientific law or whether it will continue forever is arguable,
but so far it's driven the revolution.
My argument in the book is that the problem with most,
or it's not a critique of Moore's law and you can't really criticize most or
it's just an observation about the way the world works and the way technology
works.
But my observation about Moore's law is it's,
it's,
the technology has moved so fast that it's actually got beyond humans.
We are being out run by technology and I think that explains why we're feeling
increasingly uncomfortable,
awkward,
disempowered in the face.
Not only have all this amazing new technology,
uh,
from the Internet to AI to a augmented reality,
to a,
um,
smart machines and all the rest of it,
smart cars,
but also in the context of large companies like yours.
And a lot of people feel
intimidated to put it politely by large,
by the large platform players.
There are many of them.
You know who the others are.
Um,
so that's the reality.
So how do we catch up with Moore's law?
How do we as humans catch up with Moore's law?
So I invent the beginning of the book in chapter one,
another kind of Moore's law.
This one is derived from Thomas Law.
Thomas Moore,
the author of a Utopia 16th century Englishman.
Most of you would have read his or certainly familiar with his books from
university or school.
Uh,
he,
of course,
famously road.
Yeah.
Are we good now?
Oh yeah.
So he wrote,
he wrote a youth,
I would argue he wrote a very realistic book,
which is in part a critique of Utopia.
But in the book,
the heart of your topia more's utopia I think is a reminder to people that the
core thing about their responsibility as humans is agency to take responsibility
for society and to build a better world.
What more was reminding people in the 16th century,
particularly in the light of Luther and predicts predestination and all these
incredibly disruptive,
traumatic scientific discoveries,
which suggested that we weren't at the center of the universe and the God was so
infinite.
Didn't matter how we behave.
We were still,
you know,
our faith was determined before we were born.
What more was reminding people is actually human being still count.
That's for me,
what Moore's law is about.
It's all about the agency.
My definition of humans in the 21st century is that we've invented these smart
machines or people like you are inventing these smart machines that can do most
things,
but the one thing they can do is have agency.
So the challenge for us in this age,
not in smashing technology,
not in controlling it,
not necessarily in breaking up Google or Facebook or Amazon,
but in managing the world,
in building a better world that reflects our interests rather than the interests
seemingly of technology.
Not that technology has its own interests or the interests of large platforms.
Moore's law is the guiding principle of my book.
And I reminding people that the dominant theme in the 21st century is human
agencies.
The one thing that distinguishes us from smart machines because the otherwise
smart machines can do everything that we can do.
And I think we,
we,
we obviously agree that the,
the,
the Internet age has thrown up a whole lot of,
of issues and society these days has all kinds of things that are,
uh,
on appealing,
um,
uh,
butter and you kind of come up with,
with five fixes that will help the future.
They're not,
I mean,
they're not very controversial are they know they're not having more
controversial.
Maybe you can rattle them off quickly.
Well,
it's important to remember that my argument is that we've always had five fixes
as human beings,
five broad areas where we've been able to deal with disruption and build a
better world and sort of like articulate more as well.
The first is innovation companies like Google.
The second is regulation of companies like Google,
perhaps.
The third is a consumer choice and worker's choice.
The fourth is citizen engagement,
which is a kind of pure manifestation of Mozilla and the fifth is education and
every time there's a great disruption,
whether it's the industrial age or the renaissance and the reformation,
we've always had these tools to shape a better world.
The key,
in my view is that they work together.
The mistake many people make is to rely on just one of these tools.
So I think the mistake Silicon Valley has made has been to rely on the market,
and I'm not saying certainly Google Uk,
I'm not sure if you,
you fall into that category,
but of course the the Peter teals of the world and the Marc Andreessen's,
these people believe that if you just stay out of it,
the market will eventually resolve all scarcities and create a better world for
everyone.
I think we'd been staying out of it for long enough to know that that's not the
case,
but on the other hand,
of course the Europeans or you will probably tell me the Europeans are too
fixated on regulation,
which maybe there's some truth to that,
so you need a mixture of the,
the the,
the two,
the key argument in the book again is probably fairly self evident or they're
not.
Everyone in silicon valley will agree is that there is no app to fix the future.
There's no simple fix.
Just as there was no simple fix in the industrial age,
it takes a generation.
We need to be patient.
Then of course,
patients in our network day,
just something that doesn't always come to us naturally.
Um,
but,
uh,
I sort of used the metaphor,
the analogy of the tech stack in terms of these five tools and then mixed
together.
And sometimes,
you know,
some reg regulation is often innovative.
The best regulation,
and you,
you,
and I may disagree on this,
but I think for example,
what Margaret Vestager is trying to do in Brussels,
at least in her mind,
I interviewed her in the book.
Um,
she's trying to protect innovator.
She's not,
um,
she's not punishing innovation.
She's not against innovation.
That doesn't mean all regulation is for innovation.
But,
uh,
I think the best kind of regulation only works with innovation.
I thought you were quite won over by Mrs [inaudible].
Have you met,
did you learn that famous office?
She was probably nicer to me than she was to you.
She seemed very nice to you.
Definitely.
Very,
very helpful.
But I actually,
you come out in favor of some things that are perhaps quite surprising that you
seem to be championing or supporting.
I was quite surprised by Singapore for example.
Uh,
and you,
you accept that it's not utopia,
but you're sort of theme is,
uh,
the people who are trying to build digital utopia and you point to Singapore and
Estonia.
Estonia is my best model.
If there is a utopia,
it's Astonia small country,
unique,
obviously post-soviet place,
which benefited because it was in the old Soviet Union.
It was the sort of,
uh,
it was,
the,
the place where they,
they had good technical universities.
Now is I think the most wired,
the worst network place in Europe with tremendous,
tremendously innovative policies in terms of east citizenship,
in rearchitecting,
uh,
a social contract between consumers,
or between citizens and government over data.
I think you're right on Singapore.
I'm ambivalent about Singapore.
I think what Singapore is doing on smart,
on their smart nation initiative is interesting.
But of course,
the big question with Singapore is,
uh,
the lack of democracy and the fact that as the nation becomes smarter and
smarter in a,
in a country without d democratic accountability,
one can become quite nervous of the power of government over citizens.
I would say that Estonia is the best case.
The worst case is China.
Singapore is somewhere in between.
Yeah.
I mean you're talking a lot about trust,
trust,
trust.
Trust is,
yeah.
But trust is the,
you know,
the two great scarcities and again,
you guys know this better than I do.
The two great scarcities of are networked age,
our trust and attention.
Um,
and it's no coincidence we have a crisis of trust.
I think in a digital age,
particularly in the sort of the,
the age of user generated content and social networks where everyone is
continually undermining authority.
Now it's not just because of the Internet.
You Know Fox and MSNBC and I'm sure a lot of English TV stations do the same
thing,
but there is a connection between the crisis of trust and the appearance of sort
of network culture.
But do you think people in in this country or indeed more broadly and in Europe,
would it accept government intervention at the,
at the level that the dystonia and Singapore do and would trust him cause level
the level of trust among Singapore citizens?
Citizens and their government is remarkably high.
But I think you could try to do what Singapore does in the UK.
You might get a regiment.com where it's chicken and egg.
I mean the,
the crisis in England,
it's both England and America I think have a crisis of legitimacy of democratic
institutions are sort of redundancy of political parties and ideology.
So where do you start to rebuild that?
Um,
the Estonian model is interesting in that,
um,
I,
I use the Edelman Trust Barometer,
which is the sort of the gold standard for determining who trusts what and it's
always falling every year.
It's amazing how lucky he releases it every year at Davos and every year it's
the same story.
There's less and less trust.
But what do you think he found in Astonia was people trust the government,
but they may not trust the political parties,
which is interesting.
Um,
I'm on the data front.
I think what the Estonians are doing is interesting because they are,
I talked to the former Estonian president who was the real architect of many of
their reforms.
This guy called [inaudible] very charismatic figure.
His argument is that
privacy is history.
His argument is in the age of smart everything,
it's increasingly difficult if not impossible to maintain a kind of 19th century
version of privacy.
The one that was protected in laws by people like Louis Brandeis in the u s and
John Stuart Mill and the UK.
So what,
what these stone have tried to do is say,
okay,
well with all the digital reforms at the Estonians are doing,
the government is going to know a lot about you,
your health records,
your tax records,
your car wreck was,
everything is online.
It's stoner is the first country to really go online.
What the Estonians are trying to do,
and I'm,
I'm sure it's not perfect,
but it's an interesting idea,
is to say,
look,
we do know everything about you,
but if we choose to look at your data,
we will tell you.
So the government has an accountability.
It's a kind of almost,
it's not based on blockchain technology,
but it's a blockchain like thinking which may be one way of rethinking a social
contract.
Um,
you know,
we can cling to our romantic notions of privacy.
I'm just not sure how realistic that is,
particularly since we're on the verge of,
you know,
smart everything from cars to cities to bodies.
I don't quite know in this age how we protect our privacy either from companies
like yours or from governments.
So perhaps rather than trying to do that,
which is a kind of Sisyphean task,
it might be better to force the government under law to be much more
accountable.
So I think what the Estonians are doing is interesting.
I think I'm more,
I,
as you can tell from the Singapore chapter,
I'm a little bit more ambivalent,
but I think it's too easy for,
you know,
British or American people to write off the Singapore experiment.
It's a miracle and economic terms,
they have the best education system in the world.
They have a remarkably innovative economy.
So to write them off as sort of neo authoritarian,
I think it's slightly unfair.
You are your clearly pro government,
you're pro statism.
Is that,
would you agree with that?
No.
Let me explain what you mean.
I mean,
and give me an example of that.
You're in favor of the,
the intervention of,
of governments to regulate.
I am in favor of regulation as one of the five tools.
I believe that the biggest mistake in America was they sort of retreat of
government from the digital terrain.
I think you guys got very lucky with safe harbor.
You guys,
you know,
Eric Schmidt did a very nice job on barrack Obama.
Um,
and uh,
you know,
God knows what Trump's up too,
but I think that the es state,
you call it,
whether it's the government and elected government has a responsibility to
regulate some aspects.
And I used the example of the industrial revolution with other industries.
So we look at food,
uh,
without the regulation of the food industry,
we'd all still be poisoned without the regulation of labor laws.
You'd still have 11 year olds in,
in working,
in factories without regulation,
uh,
unions would still be out load.
So I think we have to be realistic.
Just this is an English audience in America.
I think people hear a little bit more realistic about this.
In America.
Anytime you suggest any kind of regulation,
you're accused of being a stolen this,
which is absurd.
It's just one piece of the puzzle.
One bit of the stack.
But to deny it significance I think is extremely unwise.
I think it's unwise of you as well.
Not You personally,
but your company.
I think you and I think you are acknowledging the government is a reality.
I mean wherein Steve Case's third stage where politics becomes relevant.
I mean if you didn't realize that you wouldn't be spending so much money
lobbying in Washington DC,
it's not a bad thing.
We need accountable government.
I'm very disappointed in many ways with the u s government.
Uh,
but I think the,
the EU government is doing a better job,
not idea.
I think some of the things that some of the European states doing are absurd.
You know,
the,
the French Spanish initiative to force Google to pay newspapers for sending them
traffic from Google news is obviously absurd.
It's an example of,
of,
of shortsighted,
of counterproductive regulation.
Not all regulation is right,
but I think the GDPR is an interesting initiative to make data portable.
I think investigators work in antitrust and taxation is important.
And I thought that,
I thought the comparison you made with,
I mean do you agree I was going to make these avoiding the quest.
I thought the,
the comparison you made with the car industry and Ralph Nader unsafe at any,
at any speed was a very compelling one.
The only difference I would make there is that the,
because of po poorly designed cars,
literally millions of people died.
Yeah,
that's true.
But so,
so my argument about the American car industry,
and again,
I'm speaking to you,
I guess we're in Britain,
but you're still an American company.
My,
my overall argument is I think some companies perhaps including yours,
have lost sight of their customers in,
I don't know who your customers are,
their users interest.
So I think your business model is profoundly flawed in the longterm.
I think it's flawed because it's essentially transforms the user into the
product.
And whilst you,
someone here will argue,
well,
people don't complain,
you're right.
But ultimately they will,
I think people don't want to be watched all the time.
People don't want to be turned into the product.
And I use the example of the American car industry,
which was fat and happy in the 50s.
So fat and happy indeed that they started designing cars that were essentially
deathtraps,
uh,
Neda and 65 wrote is unsafe at any speed that exposed the bad design and lack of
respect for their users in the car industry.
And you know,
pre Tesla,
the American car industry has never recovered.
So I think it's important whether it's Google or any other tech company to think
about the real interests of what they use as well.
Now everyone,
you know,
in terms of search engine,
obviously everyone wants a high quality search engine,
which you have.
But you and I've had this conversation before,
I still think people would like to pay for their search engine if they were
guaranteed complete privacy and that their data would be left alone.
I wish that you would offer that.
I don't see why it's a problem.
And you point to examples of organizations,
other organizations who are,
who are doing that kind of thing.
I mean,
and that's,
that's the market,
isn't it?
At work.
If there is demand for it,
people will,
will come.
Yeah.
But,
but it's the old Steve jobs argument as well.
You know,
if Steve Jobs had waited for the market,
we never would've had the iPhone.
You guys know your market and the mentality of your users better than anyone.
And I think in a sense that you need to become a little bit more responsible and
accountable in pushing your users it towards say,
paying for services.
I,
I don't,
you know,
whether it's in content,
uh,
in Youtube,
whether it's on search,
I think that the biggest tragedy of the history of the web was a fetishization
of free.
I think that has been the most destructive mistake.
I think it's essentially destroyed the media industry or much of the media
industry and a spoil consumers into thinking that they shouldn't have the right
to pave stuff,
which is very misleading and destructive and subscription to something that is
coming both in,
in news,
which is good.
Which I hope,
you know,
larger companies like yours would get behind,
uh,
it offers another business model.
Yeah.
So I mean,
the big disagreement I would have with you about the book is that as far as I
could see that there literally is no acknowledgment of the benefits of
technology in the book.
And,
and the last time we had,
last time you were here,
we did prayer rather cheap shot,
which was to play you the,
the famous can we do month by the Romans ever do for us a clip from Monica,
which I haven't gotten it,
but I'm going to read the quote,
which is where John [inaudible] says,
all right.
But apart from the sanitation,
the medicine,
the education,
the wine,
uh,
public order,
irrigation roads,
freshwater and public health,
what have the Romans ever done for us?
Um,
okay.
But I could,
you know,
we're not,
don't Monte pay for now,
but we can pretend to do Monte python.
And I could say,
and I wouldn't,
but I could say
fake news,
technological addiction,
increasing inequality.
So,
but,
but my hip.
But here's the point is that we're pizza would be on that discussion I wrote
whenever,
let me come back on this.
This is not a book about that.
Everyone acknowledges that the Internet's done amazing things.
That's not the issue anymore.
We've moved on from that debate.
It's,
it's not useful anymore to be continually discussing whether or not the Internet
has benefited humanity.
Kelly,
it's done some good and there are lots of problems.
So what I'm doing in the book is saying,
okay [inaudible] what's the point of this?
It's like some sort of political correctness.
The,
every time I read a book I have to explain why the Internet is great,
but the point,
but there should be an acknowledgement.
There should be a balance because the point is when I speak to you,
you're,
you're very reasonable.
Then I read your book.
This is a couple of it.
Generally speaking,
not an unreasonable,
but we'll,
let me give you a fan of quotes from the book.
Much of the digital innovation of big tech companies like Google and Facebook
isn't currently working.
Yeah,
come on.
You can't stand by that.
I mean you can speak to your,
your phone lens in Spanish at lunch.
Let's pick on our friends in Facebook.
Let's leave Google out of this.
Do you think,
I don't know if there's anyone from Facebook.
Do you own Facebook yet?
That's next week,
right?
It's Facebook working.
It's infested with fake news.
Zuckerberg has absolutely no idea of where to go in terms of his business
strategy.
Kids wouldn't be seen dead on Facebook.
Um,
it's,
it's the perfect sort of place.
You know,
Putin spends,
you know,
millions of dollars a year hiring people to post lies on Facebook.
Um,
I think mostly,
and we see more and more research showing that kids are addicted to this thing.
Again,
it doesn't mean that everything,
Facebook is bad.
We don't need to get into that.
But I would say in overall terms,
Facebook is not working.
And I think even Zuckerberg's acknowledging,
I mean he acknowledged the most people now realize that Trump,
one of the main reasons why Trump won the election was because the Russians
gamed.
Facebook
is Facebook working.
I would acknowledge that they're,
there were definitely issues.
Our point,
our point is please hold us to account for what we do and generally speaking,
don't bundle this together and bundles together in the same sense with,
but I look,
here's another,
here's another quote which I wish I fund going a little far.
It seems almost normal for online audiences of millions to watch revenge porn,
live beheadings and suicides.
That's not true,
isn't it?
Almost normal,
which depends on your definition of what
but,
but what do you accept that there has been a profound sort to corrosion at the
culture and the um,
uh,
the,
the kind of content on,
on this media,
which is apps with wet weather is lacking curation.
It's very troubling in many ways.
The,
you know,
the,
the infestation of sexism and racism and,
and,
and sort of cults of violence.
Those are realities.
My point is,
I don't think,
I think that,
you know,
if you want me to,
I'm going to do it again.
I'm going to bundle you and Google and Facebook all together.
I think you have to acknowledge them.
We've had this conversation before.
You have to acknowledge that your media companies and that you have a
responsibility for the content that's published on your network.
You have the same responsibility as a newspaper or a movie studio.
And I think the sooner you,
not you personally,
but certain companies acknowledge that the better for everyone.
Do you do look at,
I don't disagree with that.
I would agree with what you talk about,
which is the,
the combinant tutorial approach,
isn't it?
There's no,
there's no one club to fix these problems.
It's a range of things.
And I think actually if you look at it,
hate speech or violent extremism,
correct oil approach,
what some of the things you're doing right.
What I argue though is that we can't just rely on your generosity to humanity,
uh,
that the only way that large tech companies are coming to the table to fix these
solutions is when they're threatened with major fines.
You only do it with the bottom line threat.
Uh,
it's not enough to just tell these people to take responsibility.
And that's why I think I applaud some of the,
you know,
even what the Germans are doing with youtube and some of the other media.
I think that's the only way it works.
And I think the other mistake I,
since we're on our Facebook,
Google ran,
the other mistake that's happened,
I'm not sure if this is certainly not true of you,
but have some people in these large tech is that they believe their own hype.
They,
they believe their own Koolaid or they've drunk the Koolaid so much that they've
started to believe it.
And one of the delusions of,
I think this was true Google in an early stage,
maybe not now,
but you know,
in the early days and Larry and Sergey and the do no evil stuff,
it was this idea that you could be incredibly successful and do good
simultaneously and that you,
uh,
and Facebook,
you were breaking the mold of capitalist companies.
The typical capitalist company was an oil company or a,
or a big bank and they weren't,
they may not be evil,
but they had no benefit to humanity.
The idea of the Google Ipo and the Facebook IPO and so much of the kind of
ideology that came out of Silicon Valley in the web 2.0 a jap and two maybe
three or four years ago was the we are different.
We are reinventing rearchitecting capitalism and I don't think that's true.
I don't think big tech companies at any worse than you know,
big banks or big Pharma companies,
but they're no better either.
Yeah.
I'm actually one thing that I agree,
one thing up to a point,
one thing that one thing that struck me about the book was not a great deal of
mention of of the user and I think the big difference with with with with Google
and other tech companies is that we are extremely answerable to the user and
when we get things wrong that we hear about it a very,
very quick.
I think that's a fair point.
And I still think,
you know,
the,
since you're being so frank and open,
I think one of the weaknesses of the book is that I still assume that users will
rebel and most,
I'm sure you do a lot of research and how happy your users on,
I assume they're reasonably happy.
My fare and prediction is that we still haven't had a major data event.
We still haven't had an Exxon Valdez or certainly a Chernobyl.
And I still feel something will happen.
It may be a state to state digital event,
which will open people's eyes.
You know,
I did,
you know,
click,
the,
the burden media search engine is designed to take on Google.
I did,
uh,
when,
the chief technology officer,
Belgian guy,
I think he's an old friend of Larry and Sergei,
very smart guy.
We sat in a,
in their office in Munich and he showed me how much you can find out about
anyone online if you know what you're doing.
And I think when you show regular people that they would be terrified cause
people still value their privacy.
Yeah.
And I like the line that you use about nothing,
nothing,
nothing.
And then bang and you kind of,
you're kind of suggesting that.
Yeah,
and I think it's always a time where,
you know,
no business model,
no company lasts forever.
I think since I'm being self critical,
the week,
another weakness of the book is on the one hand I worry about monopolies and
huge companies.
And on the other hand I predict the demise.
So I think there is some,
I mean I wouldn't talk about that publicly of course,
but I think there is,
oh yeah.
But Youtube edit the headings.
Are we going to have a ritual bad thing at the end?
So,
um,
towards the,
towards the end of the book you talk,
you talk about the kind of public spiritedness and an education that need for
education.
And actually you talking about the universal basic income as well,
which I think you kind of come out in support of
universal,
you know,
coming out against universal income is basic incomes like coming out against
apple pie or a,
you know,
babies.
I'm a Northern Irish Protestant.
I think it was as fossil fuels,
if you give people money without a job,
they got to spend it on drink.
But that's true in northern,
I uh,
yeah.
But what do you make of the argument?
And again,
it's a popular argument in Silicon Valley.
What do you make of the argument that,
um,
that technology may take away so many jobs that there just aren't going to be a
jobs?
What's everyone going into?
Not everyone can work with Google.
You know,
Google,
what's the market cap of Google?
It's almost a trillion.
How many people work for you?
70.
80,000.
Yeah,
I mean,
exactly.
So,
and,
and we know there'll be less and less as AI becomes more and more central in
your company.
Um,
the thing about what I like about the guaranteed minimum income is it's thinking
big.
Just as in the middle of the 19th century,
there was no social security net,
no way of protecting unlucky workers from the ravages of cap industrial
capitalism.
So Bismarck who certainly was anything but a socialist,
pioneered social security.
Then it was developed in Scandinavia,
in the UK.
And then in,
in the u s um,
I think we need to be thinking in those big terms.
My problem with universal basic income is it seems to satisfy the conscience of
Silicon Valley billionaires like Sam Altman.
But I'm not sure if we have,
you know,
80% of the people in our,
in our society living on $2,000 a month,
uh,
the whole world will look like San Francisco,
but you know,
a few noblemen and barons in their mansions and everybody else living out on the
streets.
So the problem I think with the universal basic income is it can kind of
institutionalize the,
already have the inequalities of our age.
And you're right,
I mean,
look,
we are,
we,
you and I grew up in,
in,
in the age of the doll in the UK where a lot of people did just say on the doll
and do nothing and drink and watch TV.
Um,
so that is an issue,
but I think we need to think creatively in the book I A,
I go to Switzerland,
which is the first country to have a referendum on it.
This is becoming a real issue.
It's a real issue in Finland.
It's an issue in Canada.
It's an issue in Brazil.
We need to think big.
We can't just fall back on the old certainties cause they don't work.
I mean,
what do you think about every economist from,
you know,
even McAfee and bring Johnson who are relatively optimistic,
are concerned about the,
of smart technology on jobs?
Just because technologies in the past have created jobs,
doesn't guarantee it in the future.
Um,
so I do think we have to acknowledge this and if indeed this technology,
as many economists predict,
do put 30 40% of us out of work,
we've got to come up with something.
Otherwise,
you know,
there's revolution on the street.
People are,
you know,
people have nothing to eat.
It's an important issue too to think about.
Yeah,
I would say that,
you know,
the,
the experience of history is that technology has made the world a better place
every single time throughout history.
And there's no reason to suppose that the Lord the last have is going to be any
different.
But it doesn't mean that there's not bumping.
And sort of the pen,
right?
But that's a sort of a linear view of the world.
I think if you lived in Germany in the 1930s technology wasn't making the world
a better place.
Certainly the experience of the Soviet Union didn't make the world a better
place.
So you can,
you can find examples of how the industrial revolution work and you can find
examples of how industrial revolution failed.
And even,
you know,
I talk about environmental regulation and the way in which,
uh,
the industrial revolution in that sense has been tamed.
But we know from people like Naomi Wolf that,
you know,
global warming remains a huge problem,
may indeed be the biggest problem of all or with,
with smart smart machines.
So,
um,
I guess it's bumpiness along the way and that's the purpose of,
but it's not a bad,
but my book is a mat.
I use the metaphor of the map,
but it's not like a Google map where you go from point a to B.
It's a much more complicated math.
The future is not linear.
And just as we move forward.
So there'll be new challenges,
new opportunities.
There are many routes into the future,
many opportunities.
So I think there was also no singular route.
As you know,
the book is,
you know,
it deals with Dystonia in Germany,
in Europe and the u s in India and Singapore.
And I suggest that there are many routes and that the idea that the internet
creates a one world global village,
I think has been proved to be wrong now doesn't mean I glorify what's happening
in China or Russia,
but I think we have to acknowledge the reality of the splinter net that is the
future of the digital world for better or worse.
Okay.
We're going to get some questions from the audience in a second.
So get ready,
but just,
I just,
just before that,
just some quick questions.
What one word answers or actually at a symbols or sums up big sums up our big
thumbs down.
Okay.
Take some APP or pick them down.
Bitcoin
and what says
on balance?
Are you in favor or is it a good thing or a bad thing?
More.
More or less than 50% favorability.
What can I say that?
But then I would say for blockchain,
that okay to do that.
Okay.
Uber,
I use it all the time,
up and down,
up.
Especially since Travis isn't there anymore.
Adblock plus up up.
It's amazing.
What do you think?
But you,
you've appropriated that,
right?
I haven't you built that into chrome while we,
we,
we've acknowledged that.
The reason we ask you this question since we're all family here,
what's on you killing your own business by introducing adblock into,
into crow,
trying to make the,
the improved the overall ecosystem in which we acknowledged the real problems
and that the political next thumbs up or thumbs down.
Karl Marx,
I'm still on Facebook or you know that one.
Google.
I,
since I'm here in New Orleans,
I'm as I'm as Google does anyone,
I probably use it a million times a day.
Right?
What I don't have though is a Google account.
I had to do this interview on,
you still have this thing.
What is it?
Google chat.
Uh,
there was a guy,
you,
what's the thing you screwed up in social media plus year or Google chat room or
something,
but I didn't have a Google account.
I don't use Gmail.
So I sort of have this romantic idea that none of you are watching me,
although I'm sure you are because I just use the search engine without having a
GML or account or a chrome account.
So,
but I,
you know,
Google has,
I couldn't write my books without Google.
I could write my books without Facebook if I'm not on Facebook.
So yeah.
Questions.
Oops.
Sorry.
Microphone and very fair questions by the way.
Peter is a gentleman.
Hey Andrew.
Thanks.
Bye.
Thanks for writing another great book about us.
Thank you.
I think it's a great book.
You'll be ready.
I've just skimmed a little bit of it.
It's enough.
Um,
I was actually skimming the bits about to start her and in Brussels.
I think everyone in this room would agree that there is a need for regulation.
And,
uh,
in some of the examples that you cite,
things like the Corvair or meet safety,
food safety regulations,
even antitrust,
going back to standard oil,
it was always based on evidence.
And I think that what I see a little bit in the bits of your book that I just
skimmed and a lot of this discussion around these issues,
there's a lot of rhetoric,
a lot of argument,
not a lot of evidence.
Wow.
That's the guy has a,
again,
I'm not represent,
she would just relying on her,
right.
Well,
she's not some schmoe off the street.
I mean she has what,
three as you trust investigations,
have you guys,
um,
and the stuff on,
you know,
I,
wow.
So I'm not sure whether we can have a,
you know,
uh,
whether we have a compromise here,
but,
um,
you know,
I mean the stuff on travel,
I mean,
that stuff is real.
That's,
let me,
let me put it another way.
What we've always had is a press or people like you who write books,
you're actually are independent and look at these issues in an independent way.
Um,
there was evidence that the Corvair was deadly before regulators intervened.
And it wasn't just Ralph Nader standing up saying like,
I don't like this car.
We
actually based regulation on a system of rules and a system of evidence.
And I think what's interesting about the internet is that nobody feels obliged
to use those standards anymore.
Maybe the standards should shift,
but I don't think that the discussion,
but let's use the example of Uber.
You know,
recently I saw a report this week that suggested that the average Uber driver
runs three,
three pangea $3 50 an hour.
Um,
and in the book I talk about the way in which again,
I won't pick on it.
Were there other sharing companies do the same thing on not conforming to laws
in terms of protecting the rights of their workers?
I mean,
these are real things.
they're not to be ignored.
It doesn't make them necessarily robber barons.
They may not be equivalent of the textile mills where people lose their arms.
Um,
and you know,
11 year olds slave away,
but still it's a problem.
These are issues that need to be resolved.
Um,
you know,
fake news is another huge issue that has implications in our politics and our
culture.
Uh,
the impact of,
you know,
a technology in terms of addiction is also very real.
So I think it's unfair to say that those things,
right,
they have to,
each one has to be this.
No,
I agree.
But you,
so you're particularly talking about antitrust.
I mean,
look,
you know,
a little bit more,
you'd kill me on an attic trust argument,
but I,
I'm not sure you'd kill vaster guy.
I mean,
she's killing it with this work in progress.
Um,
question here.
Ah,
hi.
I want to ask a question.
So you're kind of what to be bitten to tech companies and responsibility for
fake news,
lack of democracy is spread,
Jim of sexism,
racism and so on and so on.
But,
oh,
you kind of mentioned it in your talk and uh,
but isn't like the tech companies,
they are the light that shone and showed that there are problems because they're
always been there.
And just the smartphones gave access to,
um,
express themselves to Uber drivers,
which was before reserved to Oxbridge educated white,
uh,
a man who are,
you know,
writing in the times.
Now everyone can express themselves and suddenly we see all this,
you know,
five.
Yeah,
I'd be making this change.
I,
I feel,
you know,
I've,
I've been arguing against the idea that somehow it's that the elderly,
I mean you have new elites.
Firstly,
I mean,
you have people with,
you know,
millions of Twitter followers,
huge youtube following.
So we have a new elite that maybe it's not an Oxbridge or leave,
although I'm sure some of these people went to the top universities.
In fact,
if anything,
I think that we have,
uh,
um,
a sort of a narrow elite and the disappearance of,
of,
of a middle in,
in,
in this culture.
And I'm not blaming,
we'll take,
I mean,
you can't blame Facebook or youtube when people,
you know,
when people do really nasty things,
but I do think that I'm the low,
there needs to be more accountability because otherwise,
how'd you clean it up?
Um,
the problem is,
again,
without wishing to acknowledge their immediate company,
they're not hiring curators.
And the only way to fix the problem is not an algorithm but through people.
And it's also a way of creating jobs.
Hi.
I wanted to touch on what you said on ubi.
Um,
and I agree with you that we have a certain amount of responsibility for
disruption in the job market and automation,
all of that kind of thing.
Um,
but I would argue that actually we need to think even bigger than ubi and think
about how much actually what we put a monetary value on.
So for instance,
and there's also like a feminist argument here that a lot of care work,
et Cetera,
doesn't have a monetary value or sort of stuff that you could do emotional
labor,
the good,
good in society that we don't put a monetary value on.
And actually society should be valuing that.
So actually that was kind of swayed of things.
I think that it isn't controversial to say we should have a universal basic
income for those people.
And what are your thoughts on that?
Well,
I think that,
um,
what the smart machines and doing is making us realize that certain human things
like empathy and sympathy and the ability to communicate,
these are the things that we need to focus on.
And I think we need reforms.
And in my education chapter,
I focus on this with Waldorf education and other humanistic traditions.
So I think you're absolutely right and I think that,
you know,
it's clearly technology is beneficial in many ways.
I mean the invention of the washing machine was one of the most remarkable
inventions in human history.
Liberated women from,
you know,
cleaning clothes,
which is a remarkable step forward.
Obviously no one would ever criticize that.
I think you're absolutely right.
Um,
so the,
the key though is to figure out how,
if you'd like to monetize empathy,
what kinds of new companies are going to exist that build that business models
around empathy,
the services.
And the product.
So you know,
you may,
it's the old dog human.
You may have machines that can detect sickness and illness and disease,
but you won't have machines that can tell someone that they're sick.
That's always going to be a human thing.
I have you want to quit?
You asked the question of what?
What are humans good for?
What I think we humans are good for agency.
Humans are good.
Eh,
this might seem a,
an avoidance of the question,
but humans are good for the very things that smart machines can't do.
And,
and the smart machine age.
Now the idea I,
I'm a little wary of defining humanity.
It's such a big word and it's so kind of meaningless and amorphous.
So I argue that every age we have a different definition of what humanity is.
And I suggest in the 21st century what it means to be human is being able to do
things that smart machines can't too.
So it's,
it's the empathy,
it's the,
it's the agency stuff that,
that I bet that licensed the book.
I do have one question for you guys.
Maybe you can answer or maybe there's someone in the audience I'm interested in,
um,
in the,
I do have one section on kind of moral responsibility of the new elite.
What you think the responsibility,
not necessarily of you individually but of the senior executives at this
company,
particularly uh,
the founders of the company,
how they should actually be an,
I want to just pick on them.
I mean you could include Zuckerberg as well and Benioff and be Zos what they
should be giving back to society and whether the analogy of a Carnegie is a
useful one in 19th century rubber bearings.
So,
you know,
I thought that section was was interesting.
I knew you spoke,
uh,
pleasantly about deep mind.
It gets good press on the I actually,
interesting you didn't mention Sundar Pichai at all in the book can again,
I think because I had,
well yeah,
I think you shoot on it and I think actually soon that's probably,
I would probably agree broadly with your,
your five principles.
I mean the way,
what about Larry and Sergei?
I,
I think they would to an Eric,
everyone,
the whole guy.
I make it very clear in the book,
and I'm not against the market and,
and I'm not against capitalism,
but on the other hand that doesn't justify everything.
I just did an interview with Chris Shoes,
the cofounder of Facebook in the beginning of his book.
He said he made half a billion dollars for three years of work as an Undergrad
at Harvard because he happened to share a dorm room with Mark Zuckerberg,
got very lucky,
acknowledged.
He got very lucky.
He says,
that's wrong and I think your point is a fair one.
I might look,
my book can't deal with everything.
Pick a tea has already written and a number of other economists have written
important books about the inequality,
seemingly inherent in contemporary capitalism.
I,
I'm not an economist and I couldn't really address that,
but I,
I agree.
I think the problem is one of contemporary capitalism,
but increasingly it's becoming digital capitalism and the kind of wealth that's
being created for individuals.
I think it's just unhealthy for everyone,
including them.
I mean in the book,
I suggest,
I think the nine wealthiest people in Silicon Valley,
if you add up all their wealth,
it's the same as you know,
2 billion people in the world.
That's just unacceptable.
Now,
you can't blame silicon valley for that,
that playing by the same rules.
They're not,
they're not acquiring that wealth illegally,
but it is a huge problem and ultimately it doesn't benefit the tech community
because you have the vilification of tack.
Tack is,
you know,
when you have Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth Warren and Ted Cruz and Steve Baron
all talking about antitrust,
all saying that there's a problem in silicon valley,
then there's a problem.
Last question here.
Um,
you mentioned that one of your assumptions is that at some point consumers or
users will rebel.
Um,
what do you think would be the tipping point?
What would it take?
What does I said I,
I think,
uh,
a major when it comes to say your business model,
a major data event,
uh,
David Kirkpatrick,
who was a very well known and responsible respect to tech journalists.
These used to be the tech editor of fortune.
He wrote the book on the history of Facebook.
I bumped into him at ces,
uh,
in,
in January.
He said to me that there's rumors that the Chinese government is actually
acquiring all the data of everyone in America.
And that's a sort of form of economic or data wall.
Now,
I dunno if that's true,
but people like Coke Patrica talking about that it becomes a reality and it's
clear with what the Russians have done in terms of American democracy.
It's clear what the Russians are doing with every election in Europe,
from Italy to check us,
check Czech Republic to the UK and Brexit,
that
that there are a lot of problems with what's going on in the day to work in
politics.
So I think stuff,
you never know what's going to happen,
but stuff will happen.
Stuff so serious that it will wake people up.
You know?
No one could have,
I guess you could have predicted to know well,
but no one did until it happened.
And then it seemed obvious and inevitable and the same will happen.
I think your champion,
this is really my message to Google,
is your dominant.
You've won,
you think you've won or I'm not taking you.
But it seems to me as if you think your,
you're so far ahead that you can't be caught.
I think as always in human history,
the rules of the game change with,
you know,
Harold Macmillan's famous remarks about,
why,
why did you change your mind?
He said,
events dear boy events and that's what's going to happen here.
Events,
they're people events and then you will see,
I don't know what it's going to be.
I have no idea.
But digital is becoming central and everything,
particularly in state to state relations.
And my guests will be that somehow China will be involved.
China is a much bigger threat,
I think both to Google and to the u s and the West.
And then Russia.
I think we got it wrong with Russia.
I mean they are,
of course,
they're like,
uh,
a fly.
There were annoying flying and,
and,
and China is much larger,
much more destructive,
much more problematic in the long run and much more sophisticated in their use
of data
without [inaudible].
Thank you very much.
Thank.